secret votre ambition secrète catonné
actrice à un moment donné il faut faire
autre chose il faut prendre la parole
il faut dire que je et comment mieux
qu'en écrivant votre livre raconte
l'histoire donc de vania vassia de leur
fille sonia by sonia c'est un peu vous
aurez pu êtes-vous je voulais que ce
soit très passionnant et je voulais en
même temps faire un examen une espèce de
bilan de ce que j'avais vécu le passé
c'est comme une boucle ça peut aussi
être un réservoir pour des données
d'avenir vous êtes un marqueur de
l'immigration heureux ce n'est que par
vous êtes à bien cette réforme est
d'accord qu'est ce qui vous a sauvé
qu'est-ce qui bouta booster écoutez
c'est la curiosité c'est quand même si
ça la france c'est que c'est un tremplin
pour ceux qui veulent réussir
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
en direct sur rt france pour une heure
et demie d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités
nos reporters par skype une émission
essentiellement consacrée à la crise du
coronavirus en france et dans le monde
en france précisément le ministère de la
santé annonce 833 nouveaux décès ces
dernières 24 heures portant le bilan de
l'épidémie à plus de 8000 900 décès dans
le pays depuis le début de la crise il y
aurait eu au moins 2400 17 décès dans
les maisons de retraite précise olivier
ferrand qui annonce ce soir une
opération de dépistage de grande échelle
dans les ehpad
en europe le nombre de morts repart à la
hausse en italie alors que l'espagne
enregistrent le chiffre le plus bas
depuis près de deux semaines avec 637
nouveaux décès en 24 heures au royaume
uni ben johnson testé positif aux comics
19 et hospitalisé reste aux commandes du
gouvernement garde un bon moral
les états unis franchissent la barre des
10000 morts dans la perspective du
déconfinement le gouvernement n'exclut
pas de cartographier les porteurs du
virus à l'instar de la corée du sud et
de taïwan
si l'idée du traçage numérique des
malades bucovine 19 fait bondir les
défenseurs des libertés individuelles
celles ci restent à l'étude en france et
ne semble pas être rejeté selon
plusieurs sondages par la droite
on parlait français
[Musique]
les conséquences du coronavirus sur
l'économie et cette déclaration
aujourd'hui de bruno le maire la france
va sans doute connaître en 2020 sa pire
année de récession économique depuis la
fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale
le ministre de l'économie qui avance une
croissance vraisemblablement très au
delà des moins 2,2 pour cent l'état a
débloqué 45 milliards d'euros en
compensation
[Musique]
on dénombre donc en france 8 133
nouveaux décès ces dernières 24 heures
lié aux coronavirus ce qui porte le
nombre total de victimes à 8900
personnes sur le territoire des chiffres
donnés il y à quelques minutes par le
ministre de la santé le nombre de cas
confirmés dans l'hexagone a grimpé à 74
1390 contre 70 1478 hier olivier ferrand
qui annonce une opération de dépistage
de grande échelle pour déceler les
soignants atteint par le kobe 19 avec
l'aide est de l'a1 réserve sanitaire et
plusieurs traitements vous le savez sont
donc à l'étude dans l'hexagone les
essais notamment de chloroquine qui se
poursuivent dans 37 hôpitaux
autre piste un essai clinique qui
démarre aujourd'hui avec un produit issu
du sang de vers marins les explications
en images
[Musique]
et pour parler de l'évolution de la
pandémie en france nous sommes en direct
avec bertrand legrand médecin
généraliste est tourcoing dans le nord
bonsoir monsieur le grand merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
avant d'évoquer un le bilan encore très
lourd ce soir je voulais vous faire
réagir sur ces différents traitements
l'étude on vient d'en voir l'un d'entre
eux est ce que vous en tant que médecin
vous y mettez beaucoup d'espoir pour un
avenir proche
alors oui on avait beaucoup d'espoirs
faut qu'ils aient un traitement qui
finissent par sortir des études alors je
pense que pour le gérard nicol
s'éclairer clairement quelque chose que
nous on ne verra pas en tant que médecin
généraliste c'est vraiment un produit
spécifique pour les réanimateurs pour
diminuer le temps de réanimation et
améliorer les réponses à nos
restaurateurs se sont imaginé que vous
avez forcément des liaisons avec
peut-être des confrères dans les
hôpitaux
aujourd'hui et qu'elle semble être le
traitement qui apporte le plus d'espoirs
dans cette crise
alors j'ai sûrement vous surprendre mais
en fait on a très peu de contacts avec
les avec les le monde hospitalier
le monde hospitalier c'est vrai c'est un
monde le monde libéral c'est un autre
monde
on a souvent beaucoup de mal à faire que
faire cohabiter les deux et souvent
quand on voit un patient en libéral a
ensuite on l'envoie à l'hôpital si c'est
nécessaire et à partir de ce moment là
il ya une sorte de coupe show qui se
fait entre les deux on reverra notre
patient qu'elle a sortis de l'hôpital
donc c'est pas tout à fait aussi fluide
que ce qu'on ne pourrait penser
effectivement c'est un point important
c'est quelque chose que vous déplorez ce
qu'il n'y aurait pas une piste justement
améliorer en ce sens peut-être moins
d'eau
cité entre les hôpitaux et la médecine
libérale
on parle souvent de quelqu'un qui marche
avec deux jambes l'hôpital marche avec
une jambe
le libéral marche avec une autre jambe
si vous n'avez pas les deux jambes
vous ne marchez plat c'est exactement ça
le problème alors c'est pas forcément
illogique c'est cette recette
communication c'est une communication
logique chacun est concentré sur sa
partie mais ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
faut pas qu'ils aient une des deux
parties qui flanche aujourd'hui
précisément la médecine libérale selon
vous n'aurez peut-être pas un rôle plus
important à jouer on entendait certains
généralistes se plaint de finale manquée
cabinet aujourd'hui était vide alors
c'est un peu par sa paradoxale moi je
suis dans un secteur où j'ai une forte
densité de population et donc on a un
cluster sur tourcoing qui est sain qui
feinte qui est manifeste sur le quartier
où je suis et donc mon activité
personnelle n'a pas vraiment diminué
on voit beaucoup moins des pathologies
habituelles mais on voit beaucoup plus
de personnes en cause vide à l'intérieur
du cabinet sce qui n'est pas le cas
forcément partout dans tous les autres
quartiers
ces voix là c'est un peu complexe mais
je pense que les médecins libéraux se
doivent aussi de contacter leurs
patients chroniques de ne pas les
laisser dans la dans la nature et de
prendre tous les outils qui sont
nécessaires pour permettre cela et je
salue la décision de nos autorités de
tutelle qui ont permis en fait de
prendre le tout simplement le téléphone
comme téléconsultation parce que en
définitive c'est toujours le téléphone
qui reste là le moyen de publications
plus simple pour nouveaux médecins
justement ça allait être ma prochaine
question comment vous travaillez puisque
vous vous dites vous faites partie de
ces médecins qui n'ont pas baissé
leur activité ce n'est pas le cas de
tous effectivement puisque la plupart du
temps n'ont pu venir en cabinet vous
travaillez quasiment la majorité du
temps par télé travail par écran
interposé comment ça se passe alors on a
changé complètement notre manière de
travailler
on a adapté le cabinet pour pouvoir voir
des patients que vide et donc du coup
très clairement j'ai une zone de
déshabillage où j'ai sacrifié un bureau
pour le faire ou moi et ma femme on est
deux médecins dans le cabinet on se
change systématiquement de la tête aux
pieds
avant de commencer à travailler on a mis
en place des protections de plexiglas
pour la secrétaire pour nous mêmes on a
réorganisé en supprimant la totalité de
notre matériel de manière à pouvoir
examiner les patients deux bouts et dans
un temps le plus court possible j'ai mis
dans mon jardin des abris au cas où il
pleuvrait alors journal de la chance y'a
pas encore plus mais vraiment on a
refondé complètement notre manière
d'examiner les gens de manière à
diminuer le risque lié en fait si vous
voulez à la charge virale qu'il pourrait
nous transmettre ou que nous-mêmes
pourrions leur transmettre tout ce qu'on
sait pas exactement dans quelle
situation chacun se trouve vous avez
vous ce qu'il faut en termes de stocks
de masques notamment c'est évidemment
c'est le grand sujet non non non on n'a
pas de on n'a pas de masque pour être
très clair on a eu une dotation de 50
masques pour trois soignants ma femme
plus à une assistante qui est il était
donné en tout début de l'épidémie et là
je pourrais aller rechercher 18 masques
et c'est tout ce que j'ai eu je n'ai pas
eu d'autres masques ce n'est même pas
les bons masquer ce qu'on nous donne
c'est des masques chirurgicaux donc des
masques pour éviter que nous conta
mignon par nos postillons les patients
et non pas des masques pour nous
protéger nous on est totalement démunie
de toute protection
aujourd'hui on parlait évidemment
beaucoup d effets du
du confinement est ce que vous vous les
avez observé sachant à vous l'avez dit
vous-même que vous exercez à tourcoing
c'est un quartier dit sensible
est ce que les français de votre côté
dans vos quartiers respecte ce
confinement
je pense que quand les quand mes
patients ont vu comment je travaille et
comment on avait changé qu'on
fondamentalement le cabinet en passant
un examen le plus rapide possible le
plus minimaliste sans toucher personne
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
n'était pas du tout courant chez moi ils
ont compris qu'on était passé dans un
autre stade de la médecine qui ont été
passées en médecine de guerre au sens
propre du terme
et je pense que c'est l'effet changé
énormément après certains ne comprennent
pas certains n'ont pas envie de
comprendre d'autres sont limités dans
leur capacité de compréhension des
consignes c'est pas toujours évident de
comprendre ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'il
faut pas faire d'ailleurs le
gouvernement et lui-même pas très clair
dans les consignes qu'il donne et nous
même parfois nous pouvons péché par
excès ce qui rend incompréhensible notre
communication mais c'est important que
chacun comprenne que le virus se propage
assez facilement et assez rapidement et
donc du coup forcément les zones les
plus denses sont les zones les plus
touchées alors un nouveau bilan ce soir
comme chaque soir les 1911 décès en
france 8 133 décès de plus est-ce que
clairement on est dans le pic
on vous avait dit 1 prédit un pic pour
le 6 avril est ce qu on y est selon vous
aujourd'hui
bon je ne sais je n'ai aucune idée de ce
qui nous attend à l'avenir puisque je
vous rappelle que nous n'avons aucune
idée non plus du nombre de personnes qui
sont atteintes
aujourd'hui puisqu'on ne regarde pas et
qu'on ne teste pas assez mais
aujourd'hui les morts qui arrive en
surnombre par rapport à la courbe
italiennes sont des morts liés aux
élections municipales il ya ça fait
aucun doute sur la question 44 % de
votants c'est le frelon l'événement
majeur et on est pile poil dans le
timing des élections en termes de décès
donc voilà que chacun regarde avec
certaines ainsi une certaine
rétrospective sur les actions qu'ils ont
menées soit par défaut
de puissance à dire qu'il fallait les
arrêter soit parce que tout simplement
ils ont été totalement irresponsable et
on fait un petit jeu politique de
vouloir s'opposer à l'arrêt des
municipales bertrand legrand justement
une petite question sur ce que vous vous
dites vous vous le constatez clairement
vous voyez des patients aujourd'hui dans
votre cabinet atteint de corona virus
qui clairement sont allés voter aurait
contracté la maladie selon vous à ce
moment là c'était je n'ai pas besoin
d'être grand clerc pour se rendre compte
qu'il ya une corrélation qui est forte
aujourd'hui
si on reprend les courbes de mortalité
on se rend parfaitement compte que nous
étions en dessous de la courbe italienne
et que nous l'avons croisée à la hausse
très rapidement pile poil 14 jours dans
la f1 à partir de quatorze jours après
l'élection ce qui correspond
parfaitement à léa d'histoire naturelle
de la maladie et donc il n'y a qu'un
seul événement majeur qui a eu lieu en
france à ce moment là on peut dire que
ce sont les promeneurs et ses médias pas
44% de promeneurs sur un quai c'est pas
vrai donc le seul événement qui puisse
expliquer une chose pareille c'est les
élections peut-être le rat les
rapatriements de stations de ski sont
faits à l'arête et que le terrain mais
on peut mettre la corrélation de manière
totalement scientifique sans aucune
difficulté
merci beaucoup bertrand legrand médecin
généraliste à tourcoing dans le nord
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france le dépistage mais si fin on l'a
dit qui n'est toujours pas à l'ordre du
jour dans notre pays en revanche il
tentera d'être simplifiée pour les
soignants et les patients à risque muni
évidemment d'une ordonnance d'un médecin
il reste rations à paris où depuis ce
matin un drive de dépistage a été
installé au pied de la tour eiffel la
capacité de test de ce driver très
limité 60 à 80 test par jour seulement
loin de ce qui se fait évidemment dans
dans trois pays les rendez-vous on en a
pris une trentaine aujourd'hui
mais quand on fonctionnera à plein
régime ce sera aux alentours de 60 80
par jour ça s'adresse au personnel
soignant mais également tous les toutes
les personnes qui sont dans les
indications c'est à dire les patients à
risque qui sont symptomatiques les
femmes enceintes les personnes de plus
de 70 ans toutes les personnes qui sont
concernées par les indications est
définie par la haine et les français
entreront demain dans la quatrième
semaine de confinement les parents
doivent malgré tout assurés d'être
scolarité à la maison c'est pas quand le
retour en classe aura lieu chose
certaine cela se fera progressivement
c'est ce qu'a indiqué jean michel
blanquer r le ministre de l'éducation ce
week end
en attendant la tâche est rude elle
n'est évident pour personne y compris
pour les profs rania berrada et andrea
lowe bourgeois sont allés à la rencontre
d'une enseignante à paris
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui comme
comme au début de la dernière séance
pourrait lever la main lui donne la
parole et puis on vérifie bien si vous
arrivez en fait un communiqué il est 13
heures ce vendredi et natacha coup-ci
professeur d'histoire-géographie
s'apprête à faire cours à sa classe de
seconde
depuis la fermeture des établissements
scolaires elle doit passer par la
plateforme du cned le centre national
d'enseignement à distance un outil
quelque peu déstabilisant pour cette
jeune professeur de 32 ans
c'est vrai que ce qui est difficile
c'est vraiment en fait cette disparition
de l'humain et cette substitution en
fait complète d'un élève virtuel un
élève qui en fait alors serait d'un côté
l'élève parfait c'est à dire qu'il nous
prend la parole que contre 8,2 on donne
qu il qu'on peut le virer de la salle de
classe et d'une stupidité sans avoir le
moindre rapport à faire c'est très
disciplinés aux siens comme système mais
en même temps on sait bien que par
derrière l'élève parfait il n'existe pas
puisque on les a vus en vrai on les
connaît aussi jusqu'à présent natacha
qu'aussi n'a reçu aucune formation pour
utiliser la plate forme et doit donc
l'apprivoiser seul ce vendredi pour la
première fois elle a décidé de projeter
une vidéo à sa classe virtuelle en amont
première chose que je voudrais qu'on
fasse en sang
je voudrais qu'on regarde un petit
extrait vidéo donc pour moi aussi ce
sera un test parce qu'honnêtement je
n'ai jamais essayé ce truc là avec ce
site
donc on va essayer de me projeter un
petit extrait vidéo alors à partir de
cet extrait vidéo je vous me demanderez
deux trois petites questions assistait à
un cours virtuel peut aussi être
déroutant pour certains élèves notamment
pour l'organisation qu'implique cette
nouvelle formule
je trouve ça assez compliqué comparé à
l'école car quand on est au lycée on
avait directement les cours on savait
quoi faire enfin c'était a dicté par dj
etc
la commune est pris avec nos propres
jugements et c'était enfin faut qu'on
trouve une organisation spécifique à
chacun d'entre nous et envoie sa courte
pourront pas forcément à notre emploi du
temps qu'on avait avant et tout ça rend
les choses un peu plus compliqué
l'apprentissage à domicile devrait se
poursuivre au moins quelques semaines
ce samedi le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a estimé qu'il ne pouvait pas
donner une date définitive de retour à
l'école et dans l'actualité liée à cette
crise du coronavirus cinquantenaire
demande donc l'annulation du premier
tour des élections municipales dans une
lettre ouverte adressée au président de
la république emmanuel macron ils ont
également déposé un recours devant le
tribunal administratif les détails en
images
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour revenir sur ce premier tour des
élections municipales qui s'est tenue en
pleine épidémie nous sommes avec
l'orangé ou le maire de saint-brès dans
l'hérault bonsoir monsieur gilles merci
d'être avec nous en direct par téléphone
sur rtl france vous êtes donc le maire
de saint-brès une commune de près de
4000 habitants dans l'hérault vous avez
déposé ce matin un recours au tribunal
administratif de montpellier pour faire
annuler dans votre commune les résultats
des municipales alors on le précise
puisque c'est assez rare vous avez été
élu vous dès le premier tour expliquez
nous pourquoi
mais écoutez c'est vrai que c'est une
action en justice au caractère inédit
puisque nous avons été vainqueur de
cette municipale mais nous avons décidé
de contester devant le tribunal
administratif par la voix m jean marc
maillot avocat va relier de contester ce
scrutin parce qu'il ya un problème de
sincérité du scrutin tout simplement
quand vous dites sincérité pour quelles
raisons bien quitter la raison est
simple
d'abord il faut se poser de questions
pourquoi at-on envoyée pourquoi nos
gouvernants ont envoyé les citoyens
français gagnent des bureaux de vote
alors que la veille
ces mêmes dirigeants politiques et ce
gouvernement avait demandé aux citoyens
français de ne plus se raser les
commerces dans des cafés dans les
restaurants dans les boîtes de nuit dans
les écoles qui était le lendemain
transformer un gros d'europe on a
demandé à des citoyens français de ne
plus sortir de chez eux mais en revanche
le gouvernement leur a demandé de faire
un acte citoyenne à la montée la
question que je pose aujourd'hui qui
mérite d'être posée à vomi
outre la faute aux politiques
extrêmement grave avons nous affaire à
des zincs hôpital faut que je passe ou à
des irresponsables qui ont envoyé les
électeurs français aux abattoirs
ça c'est une question qui mérite d'être
analysée et d'être posée et le moment
venu si j'avais devant moi en quoi selon
vous le rond on entendait à votre
id 1 mais en quoi selon vous ce scrutin
ont été finalement un sincère puisque
les gens qui se sont déplacés ont voté
en toute conscience c'est peut-être au
niveau de la participation 7,5 vous
pointez du doigt alors dans ma commune
effectivement il ya un gros problème de
participation des jeunes suit le
prestige principal responsable puisque
j'ai lancé un appel la veille du scrutin
sur les réseaux sociaux d'un appel dans
lequel je te demander aux électeurs de
makoun
ils sont 2500 à ne pas se déplacer elle
passera les bureaux de vote
cet appel il a été largement attendu
puisque effectivement assez libre est
détonnant
le taux d'abstention record au niveau
national puisque 90% des électeurs c'est
une des voies ne sont pas déplacés
ma liste la liste que je conduisais a
été élu puisque bien évidemment avec le
mode de scrutin que vous connaissez il
suffisait d'une seule voix pour être élu
mais avec seulement 17 % des électeurs
inscrits sur les listes électorales
problème de sincérité du scrutin
c'est la raison pour laquelle cette
action ainsi son caractère inédit mérite
d'être mené
il faudrait que l'on fasse jurisprudence
parce que nous le faisons pour le 16
pour la sincérité du scrutin mais nous
faisons également des marchés sont
investis par solidarité avec toutes les
victimes du coc beginner au premier tour
aux élections municipales alors je ne
sais pas si vous l'avez entendu sur
notre antenne en ouverture de ce journal
on a eu un médecin généraliste docteur
legrand qui a eu des mots assez durs
justement rapport avec ces élections
pointant clairement du doigt une courbe
ascendante des cas de cornas virus
quinze jours après ces élections vous
sur le terrain
est-ce que vous avez constaté peut-être
des mises en danger de la population
lors du vote de risque de contagiosité
pour ce virus effectivement j'ai un
président de bureau de vote qui était
également candidat journaliste qui est
élue ce maïs produit qui a été touchée
par le combi 19 mai j'ai des collègues
maires qui ont fait un fleuve des
présidents de bureaux de vote ont qu'a
vu l'avis des militants de partis
politiques certaines communes ont perdu
la vie à cause de ce virus
on a envoyé ces gens à l'abattoir ils
ont aujourd'hui perdu la vie il va
falloir abandonner après cette crise
sanitaire puisque aujourd'hui le
problème il faudrait qu'il faut gérer la
crise sanitaire au niveau de notre pays
mais après la foule a effectivement que
ces gens-là nous rende des comptes
voilà c'est une scène située évidence
qu'elle serait justement cette forme de
de réclamation si josi auprès du
gouvernement que faudra-t-il faire une
fois la crise passée qu'on vous dit
demander des comptes sous quelle forme
si quelqu'un vous savez je suis pas
juriste mais il y à des commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires et puis il ya
la cour de justice pour les
personnalités ne savait dans cette
affaire-là il ya le gouvernement mais il
ya également ce que je le prends pour
également responsable du maintien de ces
street est le deuxième personnage de
l'état du sénat gérard larcher qui a
incité le président de la république à
mai 2006 main mais il n'est pas le seul
les principaux dirigeants des partis
politiques français ont également
demandé le métier scrutin aujourd'hui
ces gens là marine le pen
le premier fédéral national du parti
socialiste olivier libaux monsieur jacob
christian jacob pour les républicains
ils ont demandé le média lutter
aujourd'hui ces mêmes personnes
on ne les entend plus bien évidemment il
va falloir abandonner que l'on donne des
explications et je crois que une fois
que cette épidémie sera à passer il faut
absolument que les antennes et qui nous
expliquent pourquoi ils ont privilégié
de la politique politicienne plutôt que
la santé de nos concitoyens alors à
laurent jaoul c'est vrai qu'il maniait
le micro edouard philippe heures tout
cas le gouvernement évoquait le conseil
scientifique
il n'y avait pas selon eux de danger à
ce moment là
envoyer les français votaient quelle
réponse est un argument de défense ou
même pour le gouvernement alors je vais
vous dire moi ça me fait rigoler c'est
une réponse d'amateurs christophe
castaner a adressé la veille du scrutin
un courrier à tous les maires de france
un lequel nous disait que dans le cas de
personnes fragiles depuis 2 sur 7 et 10
ha il fallait faire à un certain nombre
de passages pour que ses électeurs
puissent voter plus rapidement on nous a
laissé comprendre par l'intermédiaire
avait pris fait que le contrôle
d'identité puis se faire assez
rapidement et que si ces personnes
fragiles ou au qui avait un comportement
suspect qui tous et se prouver avec le
gros de vaud ont demandé d'appeler le
samu
alors attendez moi comme ça
extraordinaire de dire qu'il n'y avait
pas de problème on savait qu'ils 19 le
président de la république s'est
longuement posé la question à savoir
s'il allait devenir le premier tour il a
évité le chant des sirènes parti
politique est aujourd'hui le constat est
là et déjà invité en jean et déjà ça
c'est incontestable
merci beaucoup laurent jaoul maire de
saint-brès dont l'hérault d'avoir écrit
avec nous en direct ferté france dont
quelques instants rester avec nous
partirons au royaume uni où boris
johnson hospitalisés reste tout de même
aux commandes du gouvernement il dit
avoir bon moral alors que le coe vie 19
a déjà tué près de 5000 personnes sur le
sol britannique et puis la direction
suit les états unis qui s'attendent à
une semaine extrêmement difficile
un bilan qui est un plus de 10000
or ce soir aux etats-unis restent élevés
[Musique]
nous allons évoquer ici les sujets
stratégiques pour notre pays et sur ces
dossiers sensibles
je vais partager avec vous une
interprétation en france une quinzaine
de zones ont été sélectionnés dans les
années 90 par des militants dieu la
première heure de notre administration a
été de croire que les terroristes
étaient des loups solitaires alors
qu'ils étaient là résultant de 15 ans de
travail de fond fait par les analystes
soyons clairs ils ont prêché la guerre
sainte et le problème c'est qu'on les a
trop longtemps les échos il ya eu un
espèce de déni de réalité et la famille
drame bataclan pour qu'il y ait enfin
une reconnaissance générale de la
situation dans notre pays
la ministre de la justice madame
belloubet annonce la sortie en 2020 de
43 du à 10 140 avant fin 2022 sur les
531 incarcéré aujourd'hui
qui peut croire que la majeure partie
des individus mus par la haine de la
france est désormais libre ne sont pas
un défi pour la sécurité nationale
[Musique]
mais oui
nous sommes avec philippe douste blazy
ancien médecin ministre de la santé sous
la présidence de jacques chirac est ce
que vous ne portez pas une part de
responsabilité comme tous les ministres
de la santé dont je fais partie des gens
extrêmement humble et qui pensent que
bien évidemment j'aurais eu tous heures
depuis le premier jour de ma vie mieux
quand on voit la gestion de cette crise
est une gestion d'urgence le constat est
plutôt catastrophique pour un pays comme
la france
lorsqu'on est dans une guerre lorsqu'on
est au front qui était question qu'on
peut se poser
il ya des questions qui s'opposera plus
tard parce que c'est une catastrophe
sanitaire comme on n'en voit jamais
personne n'aurait pu penser que nous
serions aujourd'hui moment où je vous
parle en saturation des lits de
réanimation en seine saint denis a quasi
saturation sur l'île de france
la seule chose qui peut compter
maintenant c'est le confinement le
dépistage et le traitement et j'espère
que ce confinement sera remarquablement
fait parce que là la différence en
confinement moyennement fait et un
confinement très bien fait c'est des
centaines de l'hydre et à l'assemblée
un bon sapeur c'est quelqu'un de très
précis je vous dirais déjà à paris sans
prétention qu aujourd'hui pouvait faire
tous les kilomètres vous devrez pas
quelqu'un on ne tourne en plein mois de
novembre à bien comme ça j'aime tous mes
sauf l'anonymat l'anonyme avait cimenté
ce poids tu viens de chez toi tu vas au
boulot tu reviens personne a dit
monsieur ou madame vous êtes et les
gaulois la vie est belle en couleurs
pourquoi diable bleu vous pour vous
allez tous au noir bleu marine j'ai dû
nous c'est pas possible ça sert à rien
l'habille le sapeur fait jouer à l'ebit
son premier rôle qui ne devait pas cessé
d'être un vecteur de communication
mais la sap basé sur le vivre ensemble
via la bi
merci nous rejoindre 20h30 bienvenue si
vous nous rejoignez en direct sur rt
france cette deuxième partie d'émission
largement consacrée à la crise du
coronavirus dans le monde cette fois la
pandémie qui a tué à ce jour plus de
50000 personnes en europe dont près de
85% en italie en espagne en france et au
royaume uni l'italie et l'espagne sont
les pays les plus endeuillé au monde
mais on observe tout de même une baisse
du nombre de décès sur le vieux
continent
au royaume uni on déplore près de 5000
décès on est enregistrée 439 nouveaux
morts en 24 heures contre 621 hier au
total le pays compte 51 mille cas testés
positifs au corps d'un virus il ya une
dizaine de jours boris johnson lui a été
hospitalisé hier pour des examens
complémentaires cet après midi le
premier ministre britannique a donné dès
le pardon le ministre des affaires
étrangères a donné des nouvelles du
premier ministre et côté le premier
ministre a été admis à l'hôpital pour
des tests sur les conseils de son
médecin c'était une mesure de précaution
car elle continue à présenter des
symptômes persistants de coronavirus dix
jours après avoir été testé positif je
peux vous dire qu'il a passé une nuit
confortable à l'hôpital et qu'il a bon
moral il est toujours à l'hôpital en
observation
il reçoit des mises à jour régulières
sur les développements et continue de
diriger le gouvernement
et pour évoquer la situation au royaume
uni nous sommes en direct depuis aix
était avec bharat pan kenya expert en
maladies infectieuses c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir madame kenya merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on l'a
entendu le mini des affaires étrangères
qui se veut rassurant sur la sautée de
boris johnson le premier ministre qui
reste aux commandes qui a bon moral
on nous dit tout c'est la vérité vous
pensé parce qu'évidemment il ya toujours
des des suspicions quand un premier
ministre est hospitalisé bonsoir et je
ne sais pas vraiment je ne saurais vous
dire mais si le premier ministre est
capable de diriger le pays depuis
l'hôpital
alors s'il le dit le fait sans doute
c'est bien vous êtes confiant
comment on réagit justement les
britanniques à cette hospitalisation du
premier ministre boris johnson qui avait
l'air quand même très confiant pour de
prendre beaucoup de distance par rapport
à ceux commis 19 il ya encore plusieurs
jours
[Musique]
il ya effectivement beaucoup
d'inquiétude lorsqu'on sait que même le
premier ministre peut tomber malade
bien sûr nous voulons qu'il se
rétablisse et nous ne voulons que même
pas que quiconque tombe malade mais
l'idée principale c'est que cette
maladie peut toucher toutes les classes
tous les âges tous les groupes
nous devons donc faire très attention à
m hygiène personnelle et faire tout ce
qu'il faut afin de ne pas être contaminé
quelle est la réaction des britanniques
justement concernant la gestion de la
crise du gouvernement je le répète on a
vu de boris johnson avait pris beaucoup
de distance au départ avec la maladie y
jouant sur l'immunité de la population
ne soit en pas mettre en place des
mesures de confinement strict est ce que
c'est bien perçu aujourd'hui dans le
pays
sophos à akébé mode c'est parce que le
concept de mobilité collective a été mal
présentée
je ne pense pas que quiconque heures
voudraient appliquer des mesures qui
mène à l'immunité collective le pays
s'intéressent beaucoup et très
préoccupée par l'augmentation du nombre
des cas il s'agit du lieu hausse
exponentielle dans le nombre de cas
confirmés et beaucoup de personnes sont
très inquiètes les docteurs à l'hospital
hôpital sont notamment car il ya
beaucoup de passion les gens sont très
inquiets il n'empêche vous dites voilà
cette stratégie de l'immunité collective
a été mal expliquée mais enfin qu'est ce
qu'il fallait comprendre alors ce qu'il
aurait fallu comprendre c'est que
période après par exemple quelques
années les gens auraient été en contact
avec le virus serait tombé malade et
serait devenu immunisés de manière
naturelle
voici ce qui est effectivement le bon
cas de figure et ça change
s'agissant des collectives ils vont pas
beaucoup de malades d'un coup car selon
le système de santé ne peut pas gérer
cette situation
justement le système de santé
britannique qu en est-il quelle est la
situation sur place au royaume uni tout
va bien
nhs à renforcer ses capacités dans
différentes régions par exemple à
londres au nord et à l'ouest ainsi que
dans l'élite lynx il s'agit de lieux qui
sont réservés au traitement de tout cas
de coronavirus mais j'espère qu'ils
n'auront pas besoin d'utiliser
l'entièreté de cette capacité mais il
faudra voir comment la situation évolue
à quel point l empire lorsque secte
immense et ses nouveaux hôpitaux sont
utilisés alors la situation c'est
aujourd'hui la halle et royaume uni qui
passe la barre des 5000 morts 439 de
plus en 24 heures selon les
scientifiques le pic devrait intervenir
chez vous d'ici à sept à dix jours
est-ce que les hôpitaux britanniques ont
les moyens d'accepter d'admettre tous
les patients en réanimation à ce qu'il y
assez de lits où est-ce qu'ils vont
connaître le problème qui s'est produit
en italie et aussi en france dans les
régions les plus touchées
je pense qu'ils réussiront à gérer la
situation car nous venons de prêter des
lieux provisoire ballon entre dans les
midlands temps reste etc qui vous
serviront de tampon tour cet afflux de
patients et les personnes qui ont besoin
d'être hospitalisée le seront je
l'espère en tout cas
concernant les mesures on l'a dit le
gouvernement adopte est effectivement un
peu tardivement peut-être ans selon
certains observateurs en tout cas les
mêmes mesures qu'en france et en italie
un confinement on a vu dans les parcs
britannique tout le monde n'avait pas
vraiment respectée ce confinement quelle
est votre réaction c'est pas dans la
nature d'aider les britanniques
justement d'obéir à ce genre de
contraintes
effectivement nous sommes très
lebron et parfois il faut nous ordonné
de rester à la maison
c'est pourquoi des lois raisonnables ont
été adoptés mais si elles ne sont pas
respectées alors d'autres lois plus
exigeantes le plus dur seront adoptées
ce qui est intéressant c'est que chaque
loi devrait être mesurée devrait être
juste pour la population ne vont pas
emprisonner les gens chez eux et nous ne
voulons pas non plus qu'ils soient
contaminés
donc il s'agit de respecter un équilibre
une dernière petite question sur le
discours de la reine hier à ses cours
comment ils étaient perçus au
royaume-uni sachant que c'est très rare
que l'aco la reine s'exprime comme ça en
public
en effet le message de la reine était
tout à fait pertinent a été très bien
fait a été bien accueilli la reine comme
vous le savez n'est pas le la dirigeante
politique du pays
c'est la dirigeante de la monarchie
donne car les gens la respecte et elle
est maintenant à sa g et elles
bénéficient les beaucoup de respect car
elle a vu beaucoup d'événements dans le
pays grâce à ce très long règne
merci baratte up on gagne un expert en
maladies infectieuses d'avoir été avec
nous pour notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir après deux jours
consécutifs de baisse le bilan des décès
en italie est reparti malheureusement la
hausse avec 636 morts supplémentaires en
24 heures point positif le nombre de
patients en soin intensif est en baisse
gilles positive
le nombre total de personnes
actuellement testée positive et 2,93
1187 soit une augmentation par rapport à
hier
de 1941 patients parmi ceux-ci 3898 sont
en soins intensifs
ce que je veux souligner c'est que pour
le troisième jour consécutif le nombre
de patients en soins intensifs et
négatifs ce qui signifie
79 passion de moi en soin intensif les
patients hospitalisés présentant des
symptômes sont au nombre de 28 1976
tandis que la majorité des patients 60
1313 soit 61% au total sont isolés chez
eux sans symptôme ou avec des symptômes
légers
malheureusement aujourd'hui nous devons
également communiquer le nombre de
personnes décédées
nous avons six cent trente six nouveaux
patients décédés aussi tirent la
sonnette d'alarmé
le secteur enregistre une baisse
d'activité de 50 % et l'on craint les
conséquences économiques sur la filière
claire nico aux premières lueurs de
l'aurore le bateau de pêche de pascual
arrive au port de fiumicino près de rome
après une nuit de chalutage dans les
eaux profondes de la méditerranée loin
de la peur de la pandémie de coronavirus
les pêcheurs remettent leur masque à la
proche des côtes italiennes
le 11 mars dernier le gouvernement
italien a déclaré la fermeture nationale
des commerces non essentiels pour tenter
notamment de contrôler la propagation du
virus
une décision qui a directement impacté
l'activité de pascual vous pouvez faire
le calcul tout a chuté de 50% à la fois
l'offre et la demande également sur nos
revenus
avant je sors tes péchés 5 me par
semaine maintenant à cause de la
pandémie due couronne un virus
nous pouvons sortir que trois fois par
semaine même constat du côté de la criée
si les acheteurs venus portent masques
et gants de protection et respectent les
distances de sécurité
l'activité a tout de même
considérablement ralenti
c'est une situation particulièrement
dramatique que nous vivons en ce moment
notre secteur subit de lourdes pertes au
cours de cette période nous avons dû
réduire les ventes à la criée à trois
fois par semaine le prix a chuté de
manière significative au cours des
premiers jours de quarantaine et nous
avons vu qu'il y avait de moins en moins
de demandes
les ventes sont principalement destinées
aux supermarchés et aux poissonniers
en temps normal la jetée du port est
bondée de monde depuis le début du
confinement seulement quelques pêcheurs
qui viennent quotidiennement pour
réfectionner leur bateau en espagne une
lueur d'espoir avec un quatrième jour
consécutif de baisse du nombre de décès
mais les mesures de confinement reste
drastiques sur la péninsule ibérique est
là encore on voit des gestes de
solidarité comme des motards volontaires
pour aider les enfants dans leur
scolarité quémandait lecours avec david
khalifa une solidarité à toute épreuve
dans ce petit village espagnol situé au
nord-ouest dans la province de la
corogne plusieurs motards se sont portés
volontaires pour fournir des devoirs à
des centaines d'enfants privés de moyens
modernes pour pouvoir imprimer leurs
cours
il y avait beaucoup de garçons et de
filles qui en raison du conflit n'en
n'avaient pas accès aux tâches qui leur
étaient envoyées par voie électronique
depuis les écoles nous avons mis en
place un service pour les enfants de la
ville qui n'ont pas les moyens
techniques et économiques et qui ne sont
pas en mesure d'imprimer leurs devoirs
des bénévoles au style atypique qui
n'hésite pas à enfourcher leur engin et
braver le confinement pour pouvoir aider
un maximum les populations les plus
reculées
on estime que 200 familles ont déjà
adhéré au programme dans cette région
depuis sa mise en oeuvre la semaine
dernière
le système fonctionne en envoyant les
deux voir des enfants au conseil
municipal où les copies sont faites est
ensuite distribuée par les volontaires
formés par la protection civile et le
club de moto coluna harley davidson
il y avait une pénurie de bénévoles pour
fournir ses devoirs aux enfants de la
municipalité qui avait du mal à obtenir
leurs devoirs en raison d'un manque de
photocopies ou d'accès à internet à la
maison etc
nous avons donc pensé que pour atteindre
les ménages éloignés il est souvent plus
facile et plus rapide de le faire sur
une moto nous nous sommes donc porté
volontaire car nous pouvons atteindre
ces zones et apporter tous les documents
nécessaires et avons créé ce groupe de
volontaires pour apporter le matériel à
tous les garçons et qui en ont besoin
un projet plus qu'apprécié dans la
région pour rappel le gouvernement
espagnol a annoncé l'état d'urgence
depuis le 14 mars dernier et a été
prolongée jusqu'au 26 avril au moins par
le premier ministre pedro sanchez
les etats unis font face à la pire crise
qu'ait jamais connues le pays depuis le
11 septembre ou pearl harbour avec près
de 10000 morts comptabilisés depuis le
début de la pandémie selon un dernier
bilan ce soir le pays se prépare au pire
le gouverneur de new york épicentre de
l'épidémie aux états unis annonce
prolonger les mesures de confinement
jusqu'au 29 avril
les explications de fatoumata bakli un à
un les corps sont emportés pas un jour
sans que le coronavirus ne fassent de
nouvelles victimes sur le sol américain
les dépouilles sont entreposés dans des
camions frigorifiques transformé en
morgue
ces nouveaux décès s'ajoute à la longue
liste de morts recensés aux états unis
1200 rien que ces dernières 24 heures
près de 10000 depuis le début de
l'épidémie
c'est trois fois plus de victimes que
les attaques du 11 septembre
une comparaison historique qui sonne
juste pour donald trump qui met en garde
le peuple américain les etats unis
s'apprêtent à vivre
des semaines terribles avec je pense que
nous savons tous que nous devons
atteindre un certain pic qui va être
terrible en termes de morts mais c'est
aussi un pic où les choses vont
commencer à changer
nous approchons très près de ce niveau
en ce moment et durant la prochaine
semaine et demie peut-être même les deux
prochaines semaines
je pense que cela va être très difficile
en même temps ces prochaines semaines
sont cruciales
le temps est crucial et j'espère que
nous allons surmonter cela car c'est une
chose terrible pour le monde entier pour
réduire le nombre de victimes
donald trump a appelé l'armée en renfort
3000 militaires et professionnels de
santé commencent aussi à être déployé
dans les états les plus touchés par le
cos vite 19 comme ici à new york
épicentre de l'épidémie où big apple
déplore à elle seule plus de 600 morts
chaque jour face au manque de personnels
de santé et à la pénurie en équipements
vitaux comme des respirateurs le maire
de la ville
bill de blasio s'inquiète du nombre des
victimes sans cesse croissant j'ai dit
aux gens toute la vérité sur ce que nous
avons vu toute la semaine dernière et
cette semaine jusqu'à ce dimanche 5
avril
en résumé comme nous l'avons dit plus
tôt dans la soirée c'est qu'il y a moyen
de récupérer des équipements cruciaux
comme les respirateurs et pour les
respirateurs je me répète mais quand les
gens en ont besoin quand le médecin on a
besoin pour un patient il n'y a pas une
minute à perdre il les faut dès lors
qu'une vie est en jeu c'est pourquoi
jusqu'à présent nous sommes si précis
pour prévoir le stade où la vie
deviendra à en manquer d'ici là new york
comme le reste du pays retient son
souffle
et washington déploie des troupes dans
la mer des caraïbes objectif lutter
contre les cartels de la drogue une
décision qui pensent question à l'heure
où le monde est touché par la crise du
coronavirus françois tessier beach c'est
le plus grand déploiement militaire
américain dans la caraïbe
depuis l'invasion du panama en 1989 et
l'arrestation du président noriega pour
narcotrafic la flottille va se diriger
vers le sud à proximité des côtes du
venezuela alors que l'attention des
gouvernements et des nations est
concentré sur le court aux navires us
il y à une menace grandissante que les
cartels et d'autres acteurs et ses
rondes exploiter la situation pour leurs
propres gains nous ne pouvons pas
laisser faire nous ne laisserons jamais
faire aujourd'hui
les etats unis annoncent des opérations
antidrogue renforcer sur le continent
sud américain
nous déployons des destroyers et un
navire de combat avions et hélicoptères
de la marine des navires de la garde
côtière et des avions de surveillance de
la force aérienne doublant ainsi nos
capacités dans la région un déploiement
qui pose question alors que le
coronavirus fait des ravages aux états
unis sans mandat de l'onu
mais soutenu par 22 pays alliés de
donald trump
il intervient surtout quelques jours
après l'offre d'une récompense pouvant
atteindre 15 millions de dollars pour
toute information permettant d'arrêter
le président vénézuélien nicolás maduro
inculpé pour narco terrorisme par la
justice américaine
des accusations sans preuve et rejetée
par les autorités vénézuéliennes
qualifiant l'attitude étasunienne de
nouvelles formes de coup d'état après
l'échec juan why do autoproclamé
président vénézuélien
avec le soutien de la communauté
internationale j'ai l'obligation de
sensibiliser l'opinion publique
nationale et internationale et de nous
préparer dans les prochaines heures
j'ai ordonné
dans le cadre de l'opération bouclier
bolivarien de mobiliser des pièces
d'artillerie pour être prêt pour la
lutte pour la paix cessez le feu cessez
le feu
passons à un accord humanitaire des
manoeuvres militaires américaines qui
ressemble à une déclaration de guerre
alors que les nations unies des
organisations humanitaires demandent la
suspension des sanctions contre les pays
comme le venezuela et cuba pendant la
pandémie en équateur la situation est
dramatique on en parlait hier les images
attention en sont choquantes à guayaquil
c'est un cauchemar dans cette ville
côtière depuis le début de l'épidémie
les corps des victimes ducobu 19 grise à
même le sol l'aurai signée valentin
carpentier
c'est un silence pesant qui règne à
guayaquil
depuis plusieurs semaines la vie
l'estuaire et le lieu où le taux de
mortalité dû kovy 19 et le plus
important d'amérique latine
un bilan de 35 morts pour 100000
habitants toutes les couches sociales
sont touchées mais surtout les plus
précaires les habitants de la ville
assiste à des scènes d'horreur avec des
corps retrouvés dans les rues pour
limiter la propagation guayaquil et
soumise à des mesures de confinement
particulièrement stricte avec un couvre
feu imposé 15 heures de suite
un bilan catastrophique qui n'est pas
près de s'arrêter comme l'a concédé le
ministre équatorien de la santé juan
carlos de bayonne
les experts médicaux nous ont
malheureusement 10 et estime qu'il y
aura de 2500 à 3500 morts dus qu'aux
vite 19 au cours des prochains mois dans
la seule province de guayas nous nous y
préparons un nombre de morts
particulièrement élevé qui entraîne un
autre problème les décès s'accumulent et
les pompes funèbres se retrouve débordée
résultat des corps sans vie sont
abandonnés et la ville se retrouve dans
l'indignation et la peur mon frère vient
de mourir d'un problème respiratoire
il est là devant la maison s'il vous
plaît bonjour j'ai besoin de votre aide
mes parents sont décédés hier à 10
du matin s'il vous plaît regardez comme
je les garde
aidez moi nous sommes désespérés nous
avons aussi de la fièvre
[Musique]
à l'image de guayaquil
c'est tout l'équateur qui est fortement
touché par le virus depuis le début de
l'épidémie
quelque 180 personnes sont décédées et
plus de 3500 cas ont été officiellement
confirmés dans le pays
la russie n ans avoir mis au point un
test de dépistage exprès ce pays compte
au moins 6000 343 cas positifs et 47
morts ce test serait capable de dépister
l'infection en 40 minutes selon un
communiqué du ministère de l'industrie
la précision de ce test est de +2 94% 16
régions russes sont déjà provisionné 80
à 90% du pays le saura d'ici la fin de
la semaine le point avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine claireaux
bien ce qui change par rapport au
précédent déjà c'est leur précision
elles sont fiables à près de 95%
mais c'est surtout leur rapidité
désormais en 40 minutes et simplement en
disposant d'un équipement de laboratoire
classique
le diagnostic est posé cette nouvelle
méthode conçue et développée entièrement
en russie permet une meilleure détection
et donc une meilleure prise en charge
des nouveaux cas l'entreprise qui
fabrique ces tests envisagent de
produire 500 milles par semaine
parallèlement il est aussi désormais
possible en russie de se faire dépister
so recommandation médicale préalable
sans ordonnance il suffit d'appeler de
prendre rendez-vous et moyennant une
quinzaine d'euros plus le coût du
déplacement
on vient chez vous pour vous tester et
sous 24 à 48 heures vous recevez la
réponse par e-mail tous les moyens sont
donc bons pour dépister la population
alors actuelle 750 mille tests ont été
menés en russie pour 6343 cas confirmés
et 47 morts dépister c'est une chose
mais très télé c'en est une autre
tout comme quelques autres pays la
russie vient aujourd'hui d'autoriser le
début des essais cliniques
un traitement possible regardons
maintenant comment l'afrique du sud fait
face à cette pandémie 1600 contamination
pour 11 lors c'est le bilan de cette
politique de confinement campagne de
tests mobiles notamment retour sur la
stratégie sud africaine avec et l'admets
m
l'afrique du sud est bien loin des
milliers de victimes recensées dans
certains pays européens mais dès les
tous premiers cas le président tient un
discours alarmiste des mots suivis
d'actes et très rapidement pour lutter
contre le coc vie 19 sur son territoire
cyril ramaphosa espère ralentir la
progression de la pandémie avec une
vaste opération anti coronavirus il
décide d'abord de la fermeture des
écoles et des frontières avec les pays à
risques puis vendredi 27 mars l'afrique
du sud et ses 57 millions d'habitants en
tan trois semaines de confinement ces
derniers jours ça a été difficile
on ne s'attendait pas du tout à devoir
rester chez nous je suis angoissé d'être
à l'intérieur je n'aime pas ça c'est
pourquoi je suis sortie je suis sûr que
beaucoup d'autres personnes sont
frustrés de devoir rester à la maison
nous ne sommes vraiment pas habitués à
cette situation le confinement s'est
passé dans le calme
les affaires ont en revanche chuté je
dirais d'environ 70 à 80% mais les gens
ont fait leurs achats avant le début du
confinement
ils ont acheté énormément de choses mais
comme nous sommes une entreprise
essentielle
nous sommes toujours ouverts sur le plan
des dépistages une campagne de tests
mobiles a lieu en afrique du sud
elle mobilise dix mille médecins
infirmiers bénévoles on essaie de
sensibiliser les gens parce que certains
d'entre eux ne comprennent pas ce
confinement pas l'année du jamais vu en
afrique du sud c'est nouveau pour la
plupart des gens
à terme une soixantaine de camionnettes
pourront se déplacer pour recueillir les
prélèvements de cas suspect de kovy 19
une solution trouvée pour ceux qui ne
peuvent pas forcément se rendre dans les
centres de test l'afrique du sud peut
pour l'instant analysée jusqu'à 5000
prélèvements par jour grâce à ses
équipes mobiles le pays espère monter à
30 mille tests quotidiens pour avoir une
évolution plus précise de l'épidémie
l'afrique du sud a par ailleurs la
chance de produire ses propres masques
qui manquent sur le reste de la planète
et pour interdire l'exportation de ces
produits est bien un moratoire a été
promulguée enfin les autorités entendent
se servir des données de localisation
d'opérateurs téléphoniques pour retracer
le parcours de personnes testées
positives au kovy 19 la ministre de la
communication assure que la
technologique ne sera pas utilisé pour
espionner les citoyens restent avec nous
dans quelques instants à nous
reviendrons sur cette crise du corps
navires et ce notamment en france où
l'on dénombre ce soit 830 trois nouveaux
décès
ces dernières 24 heures l'état français
qui a débloqué 45 milliards d'euros pour
soutenir le territoire économiquement
puis nous parlerons du tracking ou le
traçage numérique qui fait partie des
solutions retenues par certains pays
[Musique]
paris 2024 vos arguments messieurs êtes
vous pour ou contre
avant moi je suis tout à fait pour mais
pas n'importe quel prix et il est hors
de question qu'une chance d'organiser
les jeux olympiques se transforme en une
véritable malédiction comme c'est le cas
très souvent moi je vais représenter le
contre parce que pour moi les jeux
olympiques c'est véritablement
l'expression du vieux monde c'est à dire
que qui ne prend jamais en compte la
question climatique la question sociale
la question environnementale
qu'est-ce qu'il faudra améliorer donc ce
qu'il faudrait faire c'est vraiment
contrôler ou centime près jour par jour
ce budget est joué la transparence
complète où tous les acteurs qu'ils
soient publics qu'ils soient privés on a
déjà un budget qui n'est pas qu'il n'est
pas sérieux et que oui ça veut dire que
nécessairement ça va être dépassé
paris fait beaucoup plus attention que
ses prédécesseurs aux questions vert non
seulement parce que c'est à la mode mais
aussi parce que le seuil haut c'est
quand même aperçu a senti passer le vent
du boulet
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons
la liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coup politique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême tous
les témoins de notre époque sont dans la
grande interview
donald trump est à l'affût de 2,5
milliards enfin en tout cas preuve pour
une première tranche de travaux on la
barrière n'est pas totalement construite
de la totalité de la frontière c'est
plus de 3000 km le président des états
unis reprend le discours qu'il avait
comme candidat le présentant les
migrants comme des vecteurs de
délinquance de criminalité
le trafic de drogue il est certain que
la majorité des migrants et mexicains ou
centres américains qui sont aux états
unis ne sont pas là pour faire du trafic
de drogue mais pour travailler
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous si vous nous rejoignez
merci de nous rejoindre pour cette demi
heure d'information il est 21h30 heure
de paris tout de suite les titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 6 avril
en fosse le ministère de la santé
annonce 833 nouveaux décès ces dernières
24 heures portant le bilan du corps des
virus en france à huit mille 900 morts
depuis le début de l'épidémie il aurait
eu au moins 2400 17 décès dans les
maisons de retraite précise olivier
ferrand qui annonce une opération de
dépistage de grande échelle dans les
ehpad les conséquences du coronavirus
sur l'économie et cette déclaration de
bruno le maire la france va sans doute
connaître en 2020 sa pire année de
récession économique depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale le ministre de
l'économie qui avance une croissance
vraisemblablement très anglade et -2 2%
l'état débloque 45 milliards d'euros
pour compenser et dans la perspective du
déconfinement le gouvernement n'exclut
pas de cartographier les porteurs du
virus à l'instar de la corée du sud et
de taïwan
si l'idée du traçage numérique des
malades ducobu 19 fait bondir les
défenseurs des libertés individuelles
celles ci restent à l'étude en france et
ne semble pas être rejeté selon
plusieurs sondages en tout cas par les
français
[Musique]
on dénombre donc en france me 133
nouveaux décès ces dernières 24 heures
lié aux coronavirus ce qui porte le
nombre total de victimes à 8800
personnes sur le territoire français des
chiffres donnés un peu plus tôt dans la
soirée par le ministre de la santé le
nombre de cas confirmés dans l'hexagone
à lui grimpé à 74 1390 contre 70 1478
hier olivier ferrand annonce une
opération de dépistage de grande échelle
pour déceler les soignants atteint par
locaux vides 19 avec l aide de la
réserve sanitaire
je voudrais aussi revenir aujourd'hui
sur un point particulier c'est le sujet
du dépistage
nous sommes en train de doubler notre
capacité de tests par pcr je voulais
déjà dit ce qui nous permet de lancer
une vaste opération de dépistage des
personnes les plus vulnérables en
mettant la priorité sur les personnes
âgées les personnes handicapées les plus
fragiles ainsi que les professionnels
qui les accompagnent en établissement
comme à domicile
le principe est le suivant tester tous
les résidents et tous les personnels à
compter de l'apparition du premier cas
confirmés de malades de coronavirus au
sein de l'établissement
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir s'organiser
de la manière la plus sécurisée possible
cela permettra notamment de regrouper
les cas positifs au sein de secteurs
dédiés au sein des ehpad pour éviter les
comptines les contaminations des autres
résidents cela permettra aussi de
prendre des dispositions appropriées à
l'égard du personnel selon les résultats
des tests un pays et une économie à
l'arrêt premiers concernés par ce
confinement les restaurateurs surtout à
lyon berceau culinaire de la france la
plupart des établissements dû fermer
leurs portes mais trouve des
alternatives pour rester solidaires
reportage luis carballo avec david
khalifa aujourd'hui si les frères barbey
pas de bruit aux fourneaux pas de
service ni même de conversations animées
avec les clients une routine depuis le
14 mars et le début du confinement chef
passionné
mon vivant et bienveillant depuis huit
ans julien est à la tête de ce
restaurant banlieue lyonnaise pour la
première fois depuis trois semaines il
est venu à son établissement mais pas
pour cuisiner au restaurant est fermé
depuis le 13 mars
et aujourd'hui j'ai ouvert les grilles
du jardin du restaurant pour que les
clients qui ont passé leurs commandes
auprès des producteurs locaux puissent
venir récupérer leurs paquets ou leurs
cagettes de fruits et légumes un
restaurant mis brutalement au régime par
l'épidémie du coït 19 au total avec son
frère claude il gère trois restaurants
et 30 employés tous à l'arrêt en ce
moment c'est sûr que rue ça fait mal au
coeur ça fait mal au coeur de voir son
resto fermé de pas pouvoir accueillir
légende pas pourra partager quelque
chose avec les gens a ensuite chez un
restaurant fédérateur dont je vois
beaucoup de monde de tout horizon et que
ouais ça nous manque
bien sûr ça nous manque on va pas dire
le contraire je suis on n'est pas en
vacances 1
on n'est pas en vacances même si le
restaurant est fermé le matin je me
réveille en dix ans
j'aimerais bien demain aller au boulot
pour julien la question de continuer de
travailler avec des livraisons à
domicile ne se posait même pas face à la
gravité de l'épidémie
ces pertes par mois se comptent en
dizaines de milliers d'euros nous avons
décidé de fermer pour des raisons
économiques c'est-à-dire que ferme
l'emporter ça engendre des frais
des coûts par rapport à un chiffre
d'affaires qui serait
quand même dérisoire par rapport à aux
dépenses donc le calcul est vite fait
les barbes et donc jamais connu un tel
séisme en cuisine et ce ne sont pas les
seuls dans ces situations la profession
on a pris un coup à lyon pour une ville
qui se veut la capitale de la
gastronomie française
la pandémie est une catastrophe
économique quelques établissements
demeure ouvert avec des livraisons à
domicile mais la plupart d'entre eux ont
baissé le rideau à contrecoeur et se met
un bruno le maire était auditionné par
la commission des affaires économiques
du sénat les nouvelles ne sont pas
bonnes la france devrait connaître en
2020 sa plus forte récession depuis 1945
sur france 2 le ministre a appelé à la
création d'un fonds de solidarité au
niveau européen capable de garantir un
redémarrage de l'économie au niveau
national bruno le maire avait lancé un
autre appel aux dirigeants du cac 40
l'avocat christophe léguevaques va plus
loin il compte déposer une requête
devant le conseil d'état afin de geler
les dividendes et grandes entreprises et
créer une contribution de solidarité
exceptionnel
il ya des dispositions
constitutionnelles qui existent
notamment le paragraphe 12 du préambule
de la constitution de 1946 qui prévoit
la fois suivante la nation proclame la
solidarité et l'égalité de tous les
français devant les charges qui
résultent des calamités nationale nous
sommes bien en présence de calamité
nationale
j'ai tout simplement que les sociétés du
cac 40 soit soumise à un devoir de
solidarité comme le sont tous les autres
français dans des conditions
exceptionnelles qui sont les nôtres nous
pensons que la propriété privée peut
être mis en suspend le temps de voir
venir
depuis 2006 et malgré la crise 2008 40
entreprises du cac 40 ont distribué de
ce 1 531 milliards d'euros depuis dix
ans c'est colossal et sava permet ça
pourrait permettre de faire face à la
relance économique qui sont nécessaires
et pour évoquer ses conséquences
économiques du virus en france son show
avec stéphanie
r économise bonsoir madame merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
et prévisions sont pas bonnes selon
bruno le maire de la france qui aurait
donc sa forte sa plus forte récession
depuis 1945 est ce que vous partagez ce
constat alarmant oui si on regarde
effectivement sur grande échelle on voit
que la france n'avait pas connu une
croissance en 2 1 2 2 % sauf lors de la
période de 2008 où la croissance était
descendu à - 2 2 %
et puis si on regarde les chiffres des
estimations de l'insee
on voit bien que il nous explique un
mois de confinement ça correspond à
trois pointes cible en moins pour la
croissance annuelle
déjà on peut se dire que on va on va
vraisemblablement en fin d'année
enregistré des taux de croissance aux
alentours de -3%
ça veut dire que le salut s'il y en a
encore un vient dre d'une durée de
confinement moins longue
ça c'est à dire que plus le confinement
qui en fait se signifie un appareil
d'une grande partie de la production
française et plus de confinement sera
long et plus effectivement il y aura un
impact sur la croissance à venir et puis
en plus le déconfinement un deux roues
c'est bien aujourd'hui peut être
progressif
ça va pas être aujourd'hui c'est à dire
qu'on va pas se mettre du jour au
lendemain à reprendre le travail et ça
va être par par étapes plus ou moins par
région et aussi par secteur donc tout ça
va mettre du temps et soran une
incidence sur l'économie donc la durée
de 2 du confinement est aussi
la mise en oeuvre du retour à la normale
est important à connaître pour
identifier exactement
en fait l'impact direct sur la
croissance française aujourd'hui
clairement lé gouvernement navigue à vue
où on s'en fout en tant qu'économiste
vous sentez une stratégie assez pensé du
gouvernement alors déjà ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que quand même
c'est une situation totalement inédite
on est on a connu des guerres on a connu
des crises économiques ont accueilli des
crises financières on n'a jamais connu
et là c'est pas uniquement la france et
l'ensemble des pays développés qui
subissent le confinement
on n'a jamais connu un une mise en pause
de l'économie avec décidée par les
autorités publiques
alors ça il est très difficile de deux
d'estimer le coût que cela représente
parce que déjà ça ne s'est jamais
produit par le passé et aussi parce que
là encore je reviens sur mon poids
premier point on sait pas combien de
temps ça va durer donc mais les mesures
déjà qu'ils ont été annoncés c'est
effectivement tenté au maximum de
limiter la casse c'est à dire la prise
en charge par exemple du chômage du coût
du chômage partiel par l'état ça a été
annoncé par bruno le maire mais aussi la
garantie de l'état pour les prêts
bancaires à hauteur de 300 milliards
d'euros pour les entreprises
donc c'est autant de mesures qui sont
prises pour essayer de d'amoindrir les
effets négatifs sur la croissance
économique
alors on se retrouve bien évidemment du
quoiqu'il en compte un d'emmanuel macron
bruno le maire qui annonce 45 milliards
injectés par l'état dont encore en
france
est-ce qu'on a les moyens justement de
ce quoi qu'il en coûte aujourd'hui dans
notre pays sachant que la dette est à
plus de 100 % 1 du pib' alors alors ça
c'est un choc de exogènes de ce style on
n'avait guère
d'autres solutions que d'essayer de
limiter un code jeudi et pour ça et
effectivement l'état français mais comme
l'ensemble des autres états par exemple
de la zone euro vous revenir se financer
sur les marchés financiers c'est à dire
que l'endettement bas effectivement
gonflé aujourd'hui on est de l'ordre de
100% du pin
quand je parle de l'endettement français
ça va vraisemblablement montée mais est
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en face on
a quand même une banque centrale
européenne qui a aussi à envoyer un
message très clair c'est à dire que lé
là pour maintenir la stabilité
financière des états c'est à dire que
elle va récupérer prendre à sa charge
une partie du risque
un qui a été émis à travers la dette des
entreprises c'est à dire qu'en gros s
elle assure que les taux d'intérêt qui
vont être imposés à chaque état pour cet
endettement ne va pas exploser ça sera
des taux d'intérêt très faibles
aujourd'hui et beaucoup de français qui
souffrent toute l'année beaucoup de
secteurs où d'ailleurs dont l'hôpital
qui peuvent peut-être légitimement se
dire ben finalement quand on on veut de
l'argent on le trouve dans certaines
structuration quelle est la réaction de
l'économiste non mais par abord l'asse
il ya une bonne gestion globale sur une
année 1 1 et on sait que a priori la
bonne gestion impose que les dépenses ne
soient pas supérieures recettes
et puis il ya faire face à une situation
inédite un choc exogène qui est ce choc
center où il va bien falloir en fait
c'était le choix c'est ou des morts par
par milliers a essayé de stopper
l'économie parce que c'était là la seule
solution alors après il y aura bien sûr
un
il y aura des démons va pouvoir voir ce
qui aurait dû être fait il ya quand même
des soucis on le voit déjà il ya eu un
manque de d'anticipation face à ce
problème là mais pour essayer de limiter
la casse et une étude américaine qui a
prouvé que finalement il valait mieux
confiné avec les risques que cela peut
avoir sur l'économie plutôt que laisser
l'économie tournait avec effectivement
un risque de mortalité qui est quand
même très élevé avec le kobe de 19
ces deux là aux alentours de 1 à 2% au
mieux de la population faites le calcul
1 à 2% de la population ça se compte en
france sur des lignes ont donc on ne
peut pas laisser si vous voulez dans
quelque part dans un état et dans un
pays développé
il n'y avait pas le choix que essayer de
trouver une solution dans l'urgence
effectivement ce confinement et après
trouver des solutions auprès des du
financement pour finalement ce qui
compte avec l'après crise c'est à dire
est ce que les entreprises
si l'épidémie va et arrive à être
endiguée parce que là aussi il ya un
donné qu'on ne connaît pas c'est le
traitement
c'est ainsi un traitement qui arrive est
bien plus vite il arrivera et plus nos
soucis seront seront atténuées donc il
ya aussi
il ya quand même que gagne comme de quoi
espérer et en fonction de ça il faut
effectivement mettre les choses en ordre
de marche c'est à dire pour que tout
soit fait pour que l'économie après une
période d'arrêt puisse repartir le plus
rapidement possible et c'est a été
notamment la décision du gouvernement de
prendre à sa charge le coût total que
peut représenter le chômage partiel
merci beaucoup stéphanie vilain
économistes d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france et si la france
justement dans ce combat se servait des
téléphones mobiles pour lutter contre le
comique 19 le tracking est déjà utilisée
on le sait dans plusieurs pays pour
enrayer la pandémie
c'est notamment le cas en allemagne au
royaume-uni ou encore à singapour après
avoir exprimé une grande hostilité paris
envisage désormais de cartographier des
malades en phase de déconfinement les
explications en images le trac l'ont
fait partie des solutions retenues par
un certain nombre de pays
donc nous avons fait le choix de
travailler en lien avec eux pour
regarder ses solutions
je suis convaincu que si elles
permettent de lutter contre le virus
et si évidemment elle respecte les
libertés individuelles
c'est un outil qui sera retenu est
soutenu par l'ensemble des français
[Musique]
cela n'est pas la culture française je
fais confiance aux français pour que
nous n'ayons pas à mettre en place ces
systèmes qui au fond atteignent la
liberté individuelle de chacun pour être
efficace donc ce n'est pas un sujet sur
lequel nous travaillons
[Musique]
mon
m
[Musique]
man 2
m
[Musique]
oh
et pour évoquer cette éventuelle traçage
numérique des malades du commis 19 nous
sommes avec erica sadun philosophes et
spécialistes du numérique bonsoir eric
sadin merci d'être avec nous je le
rappelle vous êtes philosophe donc on va
essayer justement de voir comment vous
percevez d'un point de vue philosophique
ce tracking dont on parle beaucoup moins
dans les pays comme la corée du sud
alors déjà ce que c'est une solution qui
vous paraît vous envisageable dans notre
pays avec les mentalités françaises
alors des mesures ont été mises en place
dans plusieurs pays asiatiques ont
savons celle ont des niveaux différents
de façon extrêmement fort demandé
l'assentiment des citoyens des
représentants en chine
c était à l'oeuvre en corée de façon on
à dire un peu plus un peu plus souple le
tout cela est notamment dû à la fia
niche le respect de l'ordre non respect
à plat très dominante du groupe sur les
individus nous nous sommes en europe et
dans des démocraties rentrer
immédiatement là le dessin de deux
tracés individuellement les personnes
nous et serait moi ce que je pense qu'il
faut voir cela
au delà des insectes que c'est un peu ça
semble déchaîner actuellement est en
partie à juste titre mais je pense qu'il
faut voir cela avec circonscription et
prudence cette année alors vous dites
cirque ont cessé et prudents alors déjà
il y à des mesures sanitaires
et quand on dit sanitaire le sécuritaire
est très proche qui sont en place depuis
que de trois semaines maintenant qui
nous aurait dit il ya un mois que pour
marcher dans la rue il faudrait une
attestation qu'il y aurait des drones
dans les espaces publics pour vérifier
si les personnes respectent des
consignes de vivre une situation inédite
qui nous mais qui nous place dans des
cadres juridiques sociaux absolument
inédit
et qui d'une certaine façon au trail de
court alors on y répond en sciences i
prix pour là pour la bonne cause pour la
pour la santé collective et individuelle
là nous parlons d'une sorte de mesures
supplémentaires dont il faut relever
qu'elle est a priori extrêmement
impressionnante
c'est à dire nous avons beaucoup parlé
de la surveillance numérique depuis les
événements de 2001 depuis les
révélations de snowdon li a une
sensibilité très aigu sur la
surveillance musique parce que elle
supposerait qu'elle soit globale en
temps réel la connaîtrez nos
comportements sont limitées et que tout
cela serait géré au sommet en
l'occurrence avec par l'état nous
n'aurions pas exactement à faire à cela
si on décision s'il est assis avec
l'accord du parlement où certaines
mesures nécessitent pas l'accord du
parlement d'ailleurs mes nuits non pas
vers cela pour l'instant nous décidions
de mettre en place des mesures de
traçage numérique avec des applications
alors si vous voulez je vous explique en
quelques mots un choix pas nous pensons
à chaque mois les réflexions elle est
actuellement 1 vous en prie aime est
pour ça que je dis qu'il faut voir cela
avec circonscription et précision
j'entends je vois des gens dire nous
allons être surveillés par tous des
caméras partout bientôt cet été pour
aller à la plage la part de mon
autorisation
voilà boillon a pas là de l'argent parce
que effectivement cette année moi de
vous couper mais justement ce serait
peut-être l'un des moyens de sortir de
ce confinement alors est-ce que entre de
liberté si j'ose dire bafouée laquelle
est la plus acceptable pour les français
c'est peut-être ce que oui alors déjà où
seront tout aussi postuler que le fait
d'être de ne pas être contaminé de
maintenir la santé de tous et une
liberté individuelle et collective un
officier des gens que la chair et apple
mais il va bien falloir un jour ou
l'autre et nous l'espérons tous le plus
rapidement possible sortir du
confinement est hantée ans est enfermé
des phases dites de déconfinement alors
tout cela il ya plusieurs
mesures qui sont qu'à la réflexion
actuellement et qui dont on nous savons
qu'il ne relèverait pas de mesure inique
mais plutôt une sorte de couteau suisse
de mesures détaillées aux logiques
l'obligation du mas du port du masque le
respect des gestes barrières et
notamment sont en réflexion on ne savait
pas du tout si ça va être mise en place
des mesures qui viseraient à parce qu'
il y ait une traçabilité des contacts
c'est à dire par le de touche par la
technologie bluetooth entre les
smartphones que les personnes que nous
avons contacté avec qui nous habitions
au contact d'agen à peu près jusqu'à une
distance maximale de 2 mètres à peu près
six lits à une contamination qui est
avérée dans un second temps et bien les
personnes qui ont été en mise en contact
soit informé alors voyez que pour
l'instant le projet s'il est mise en
place
supposerait qui est le consentement
personnel alors voir le consentement
individus alors vous rendez compte que
si on met cette mesure et qui va falloir
attendre l'accord du tout le monde ça
risque d'être une demi-mesure voir une
mesure à la marge
alors il y à des réflexions à mener
maintenant j'entends dire qu'il faut que
le principe de proportionnalité endroit
que décision respectée certes mais là
c'est une proportionnalité
j'ai presque envie de dire hors
proportion c'est à dire de chars en
sorte que la pandémie ne ne redémarre
pas donc je pense
si vous voulez un peu le bout de ce
premier moment de réflexion dont je vous
fais part je pense qu'il faut que en
tout cas pour ce qui est de la france
qu'il y ait une sorte de pacte
je m'explique
c'est à dire il faudrait que le
gouvernement s'il juge le président la
halle public l'état les autorités de
l'état si jusque ce sont des mesures qui
s'avère pertinente et bien qu'il ya une
sorte de pacte
c'est à dire durant un moment qui serait
appelé à être renouvelé
selon des modalités juridiques
législatifs qui serait à trouver
eh bien nous allons devoir mettre en
oeuvre certaines mesures
qui viserait à les protéger et je le
rappelle c'est une liberté à des viols
celui d'être beau ne pas être convaincu
d'être en bonne santé alors l'un peu la
question de la chronologie d'un
troisième mouvement va être décisive
et pour cela il y a des organes de
vigilance en france on sent un pays
démuni dessin pays à la longue tradition
démocratique il y a des organes de
vigiles à en juillet la cnil de mercy
pas du cru oui pardonnez moi je suis
obligé de vous couper donc dans cette
philosophie bhl est ce qu'on arrive à la
fin de notre émission même d'un cas le
message et excusez-moi de vous avoir
coupé dans cette réflexion merci eric
sadin rappelle que vous n'êtes plus le
philosophe spécialiste en tout cas il ya
il vient chantier qui appelle la
responsabilité collective et peut-être
de mettre certaines certains affecte les
médias de côté au profit de dinde un
calendrier rigoureux qui soient décidées
démocratiquement
on aura l'occasion certainement d'en
reparler avec vous merci à vous eric
sadin et dans ce contexte de pandémie
mondiale une note de fraîcheur sculpture
sur sable à gaza street art à la
nouvelle-orléans répétitions musicales à
domicile en allemagne
on voit cela en images
[Musique]
avant de refermer cette émission
d'information de dernière minute le
premier ministre britannique boris
johnson a été admis en soins intensifs
vous le savez il avait été admis hier
soir à l'hôpital pour des examens
supplémentaires il est remplacé je cite
là où c'est nécessaire par dominique
heures à ministre des affaires
étrangères qui avait pourtant donné des
nouvelles encourageantes en fin d'après
midi plus d'informations évidemment à
suivre dans notre prochaine émission ce
sera demain matin à 9h du matin heure
française en attendant les magazines
continue toute la nuit sur arte france
excellente fin de soirée à tous
[Musique]
pourquoi vraiment hollywood est née au
nigeria et pas par exemple au sénégal au
mali tout mon homme d'affaires ont déjà
des hommes comme femmes tout le monde et
businessman et c'est assez
impressionnant donc nollywood est
clairement le vent en poupe et les
budgets ce qui est gros budgets des
films à gros budget comme aux états unis
même en francs français
aujourd'hui le record de budget aux
nigériens ses 9 millions de dollars et
monter en gamme
d'un point de vue technique au niveau
des histoires racontées